[Musique]
au programme aujourd'hui dans ce set 8
sport du breakdance une étape inter
région était organisée ce samedi aux
mureaux la ville a accueilli près d'une
cinquantaine de participants venus d'île
de france et de normandie reportage golf
un nouveau centre de performance a été
inaugurée mercredi dernier au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
celui aura pour objectif d'accompagner
les prodiges français de la discipline
vers le haut niveau enfin un golf
toujours la nationale golfweek étaient
organisées pendant trois jours la
semaine dernière à saint quentin en
yvelines nous étions sur place pour voir
cette première édition de ce salon du
golf nouvelle génération
[Musique]
ils ont fait le show sur la scène du
complexe sportif collègue pablo neruda
aux mureaux une cinquantaine de bboy
épique girl se sont affrontés samedi 2
avril une battle étape inter région ile
de france normandie de break dance et
est organisée par la fédération
française de danse et la communauté
urbaine gps et ça fait du bien de se
retrouver on va dire depuis le cowitz a
repris doucement les événements et là on
voit vraiment une bonne dynamique ça
s'enchaîne bien sûr les week-ends et
surtout les qualifications dans chaque
région donc chacun se prépare un peu
dans ces régions on retrouve en fait là
dans notre région un peu les personnes
avec qui on a un peu l'habitude de
s'entraîner ou qu'on croise vu que c'est
une de france normandie mais a
principalement on va dire beaucoup de
gens d'île de france du coup c'est cool
c'est un bon bah tel pour se remettre
dans les jambes en fait c'est pas
seulement la compétition
nécessairement oui les partages la
communauté les vikings pour moi ces 5
millions servent avec ce type de
sélection aussi ça permet de découvrir
de nouveaux talents qu'on n'aurait pas
forcément l'occasion de voir ailleurs et
aujourd'hui on peut vraiment parler de
statut de haut niveau de breaker 2 et
breake de haut niveau et c'était avec
qualificatif pour la finale du
championnat de france de breaking qui
aura lieu le 12 juin à bordeaux il n'y
aurait vu de breakdance dans les
yvelines on n'a surtout pas des lieux
équipés et il ya une vraie volonté
politique
que ce soit au niveau municipal et
communautaire ben d'accueillir cette
discipline le public a pu assister aux
finales et demi finale c'était bien j'ai
bien aimé s'étaient précipités agréable
à regarder aussi est trop bien et dans
ces super bien
prochain rendez vous une battle
international en octobre au mur
ce week-end plusieurs matchs et
compétition avait lieu un peu partout
dans les yvelines en course à pied il y
avait notamment la diac 60,18 ce samedi
l'événement proposé trois distances 100
km un 50 km 1 20 km ce trail en pleine
nature traverser le département des
yvelines du nord au sud avec une arrivée
à rochefort en yvelines sur le 100 km
c'est damien cocher qui termine premier
en huit heures 49 minutes et 13 secondes
l'événement reviendra l'année prochaine
pour une nouvelle édition en fédérale 2
de rugby énorme performance de plaisir
les plaisirs oies se sont offert le
leader nantes sur leur pelouse ce
dimanche les yvelinois se sont imposés
de justesse 34 à 31 face aux nantais un
résultat qui permet aux joueurs de
sébastien rockalies de remonter au
classement et de s'approcher de la 6e
place ils ne sont qu'à deux points du
rush dans le championnat de fédérale 3
carton plein pour les clubs yvelinois
versailles s'impose 31 à 22 face à caen
le mls gp écrase petit-couronne 68 à 0
enfin où il surclasse cergy-pontoise 59
à 3 au classement les versaillais son
premier suivi par maisons laffitte oui
et 4e en football américain les
templiers d'elancourt se reprennent les
élans courtois se sont imposés ce
dimanche sur le terrain des corsaires
d'evry à l'occasion de la 7e journée du
championnat de 2e division le score à 19
à 8 une victoire qui leur permet de
rester deuxièmes de leur poule en
football en r2 où il perd pour la
deuxième fois consécutive les joueurs de
ludovic gauthier se sont inclinés 2 1 à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de val
d'yerres crohn une défaite qui fait mal
aux yvelinois elles sont désormais
deuxièmes du classement derrière
l'équipe 2 de bobigny à six journées de
la fin du championnat toujours en
football matteo guendouzi originaire de
poissy et formé au paris saint germain a
connu une belle semaine avec l'équipe de
france le milieu de terrain pisciacais a
marqué le dernier but de la rencontre
face à l'afrique du sud une belle frappe
à l'entrée de la surface sa première
réalisation avec l'équipe de france les
bleus se sont imposés 5 à 0 dans ce
match amical face aux bafana bafana
on passe au handball dans le championnat
de nationale 2 rien ne va plus pour
montigny le bretonneux les signé
montaigne se sont inclinés 37 à 27 sur
l'autre un cercle paul bert rennes les
premières du classement avec cette
défaite les yvelinoises font du surplace
elles restent à la huitième place avec
un bilan de 7 victoires 1 nuls et 10
défaites
enfin en basket en nationale 3 trappe
s'est incliné 75 à 70 sur le terrain de
bezons ce week end une
contre-performance qui stoppe les rêves
de montée du club trappistes ils sont
désormais à six points de la première
place occupée par levallois sporting
club basket de son côté le
chesnay-versailles gagne à domicile
contre meudon 70 à 66 mais reste 11e du
championnat
un centre le performance pour le futur
du golf français voici comment la
fédération française de golf a présenté
son nouveau bijou un bâtiment de 600
mètres carrés sur deux niveaux
construits au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines il sera dédié à la
pratique du haut niveau un projet à 4
millions d'euros imaginé depuis de
nombreuses années les premières ébauches
du centre elles ont été dessinées il ya
plus de dix ans donc c'est vrai qu'entre
temps on a eu la chance d'accueillir la
ryder cup mais que malheureusement ce
avait repoussé le projet mais que depuis
maintenant trois ans et bien on a
commencé les travaux de ce centre avec
d'abord la livraison de la zone de
petits jeux ensuite la livraison d'aidé
des salles de cours pour les athlètes et
enfin le plateau de performance et la
base vie sur le modèle du centre
technique national de clairefontaine
pour le football on retrouve un plateau
de 450 m² avec une zone de petit goût de
practice et une salle de préparation
physique des caméras et des capteurs
permettent également une modélisation du
swing les athlètes auront les
équipements nécessaires pour devenir
joueur professionnel
toute cette technologie qui est mis à
disposition de nos athlètes c'est pour
les faire progresser maintenant la
technologie seule ne suffit pas derrière
toute cette technologie il ya des hommes
et des femmes qui la font fonctionner
qui accompagne nos athlètes et il faut
pour qu'on obtienne des résultats que
l'on recherche et bien qui est la
parfaite symbiose entre les deux
l'humain et la technologie et c'est ce
qu'on va s'atteler à faire ces
équipements sont notamment la
disposition de 12 élèves de la 4e à la
terminale ces jeunes joueurs auront la
possibilité de suivre des cours
directement golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines entre deux sessions
de golf sur le site nous on a créé une
école qui est complètement adapté au
calendrier scolaire non quand y'a des
stages ou des compétitions y'a pus
écoles et puis sur les sols sur le temps
où c'est possible on met l'école ce qui
nous permet dans des conditions
incroyables parce qu'ils ont cours à 2 3
4 maximum donc ils vont très vite c'est
très personnalisé et ça permet d'avoir
les résultats très intéressants la fois
son plan de scolarité et de libérer du
temps pour l'entraînement avec ses
installations la fédération française de
golf espère désormais pouvoir faire
entrer des joueurs dans le top 20
mondial dans les prochaines années
[Musique]
la nationale golfweek est organisée au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de ce jeudi à
31 mars jusqu'à ce samedi 2 avril coup
de projecteur sur cet événement
[Musique]
pour nous représenter la nationale
golfweek je suis aux côtés d'antoine à
robin l'un des organisateurs alors
antoine qu'est ce que c'est cette
nationale golfweek c'est tout simplement
la grande fête du golf français c'est la
réunion de plusieurs événements qui sont
faits pour satisfaire tous les goûts des
golfeurs aussi bien pour voir des grands
joueurs sur le terrain pour la partie du
national match-play aussi bien pour voir
le matériel ici dans la partie salon et
puis pour l'essayer à l'extérieur sur
toutes les aires de d'entraînement du
golf national et tout un tas
d'animations qui permettent de de
satisfaire tous les besoins y compris
ceux qui auraient voulu jouer bon
aujourd'hui on n'a pas pu jouer à cause
du temps sur l'aigle pour les amateurs
mais voilà c'est l'état d'esprit qu'on
avait c'était de s'ouvrir à toutes les
populations qui aiment le golf qu'est-ce
qu'on retrouve comme stand ici alors
dans les stands vous avez à peu près
tous les acteurs en tout il ya une
centaine de marques présentes tous les
acteurs qui font le golf aussi bien ceux
qui fabrique du matériel des balles etc
tous les accessoires mais aussi du
tourisme des réseaux de parcours des
tout ce qui est loisirs autour du golf
de l'habillement voilà il y en a
vraiment pour tous les goûts et aussi
évidemment pour se restaurer est ce que
c'est pour un public 100% golf où c'est
pour un public un peu plus élargie ce
type de rendu alors je pense qu'il ya
évidemment sans pour les golfeurs accros
sont ravis d'être ici mais ils peuvent
aussi amener leurs familles pourquoi pas
leurs enfants il y avait un stand
d'initiation
pour les débutants et puis aussi je
pense que c'est un excellent moyen de
prendre contact avec le
discipline le sport ici on peut
retrouver des conseils et c'est du
matériel découvrir ce que c'est peux tu
es sur un petit petit gris synthétique
voilà donc ces on essaie d'être aussi
très ouvert à tout ça on l'appelle
nationale golfweek et non pas le salon
du golf par exemple pourquoi alors tout
simplement déjà parce que le clin d'oeil
au golf national évidemment qui est le
coeur du réacteur du golf français
deuxièmement elle est nationale parce
que c'est le grand événement qui
rassemble tout le pays n'a pas que des
parisiens ici il n'ya pas que des
exposants parisiens n'ont plus golfweek
c'est parce que c'est beaucoup plus
qu'un salon c'est toute une série
d'animations pendant trois jours on
avait commencé d'ailleurs par une
journée privé avec les trophées du golfe
qu'est la cérémonie de remise des prix
du golf français voilà on a cet esprit
d'avoir un événement large et qui
permette à chacun d'y trouver son
bonheur est-ce que c'est logique
finalement que ce soit ici au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
alors il est totalement incontournable
et c'est une des raisons du succès de
cet événement c'est que les golfeurs
maîtres chez eux sur un golf tout
d'abord parce que c'est le meilleur
endroit pour pratiquer retrouvez ici un
club un pointeur ou autre on a pas
meilleure installation qu'ici
deuxièmement l'image de marque du code
national puisqu'il a accueilli la ryder
cup il va accueillir les championnats du
monde amateurs et les jeux olympiques
ici à saint quentin en yvelines c'est
vraiment le le centre névralgique
il ya aussi un centre de performance qui
vient d'être inauguré les joueurs
professionnels adore jouer le parcours
ils l'ont trouvé dans un état superbe
même si le temps a été compliqué voilà
toutes ces raisons font que il n'ya pas
meilleur endroit pour faire national
golf ou le seul point noir c'est
peut-être le temps en vous l'évoquiez à
l'instant il neige il pleut c'était pas
vraiment les conditions parfaites pour
organiser cet événement danse est un peu
un 1er avril aujourd'hui malheureusement
il est réel la neige un 1er avril on ne
s'y attendait pas on a choisi la date
parce qu'elle est très favorable pour
avoir des bons joueurs on a eu un
plateau exceptionnel
jacquelin havret rosemère langage que je
peux pas tous les citer mais c'était
vraiment du très très bon niveau l'année
prochaine on espère aussi avoir des
femmes évidemment qu'ils n'étaient pas
dispo et bien évidemment on a eu cette
météo cette année c'est la dernière pour
les dix prochaines années c'est une
grande première du coup cette année est
ce qu'il y aura d'autres événements de
ce type à l'avenir une 2ème 3ème 4ème
édition ici à saint quentin en yvelines
alors je crois que avec le président
pascal grizot de la fédération qui est
évidemment le premier supporters et même
l'initiateur de cet événement on a un
engagement moral pour les quatre
prochaines années jusqu'à la fin de son
mandat pour aller jusqu'aux jeux
olympiques s'est fait trois ans mais
voilà et on espère évidemment qu'il
perdurera bien au delà de ces trois ans
puisque si on en croit les premiers en
action on a réussi à satisfaire aussi
bien les professionnels que les
visiteurs et bien évidemment on espère
profiter de cette de ce lancement pour
s'améliorer parce que on ne fait pas on
ne fait pas tout bien du premier coup
donc l'année prochaine on peut vous
promettre à la même date du beau temps
encore plus d'exposants plus
d'animations
certainement aussi plus d'ambiance voilà
on veut créer une ambiance décontractée
et festive merci anton rodin
[Musique]
fille pilato un salon du golf ici sur
vos terres qu'est ce que ça vous fait on
est content on est heureux ça lance
l'année événementiel sera aussi du bloc
national en plus ça bah c'est une vraie
réussite parce qu'il ya vraiment
énormément d'exposants en plus d'une
centaine qui sont là qui représente bien
on va dire tout le marché du golf
français même internationale parce
qu'elle était aux internationaux qui
sont là donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très très bien on est vraiment
très heureux est ce que ça vous surprend
qui est autant d'engouement ici à pour
le golf ou finalement c'est une grande
famille comme comme à chaque fois dans
les yvelines je pense que c'est je pense
que les taux longs a pris l'habitude de
ne voir que l'on les ivy n'y avait les
choses et que le golf était vraiment mis
en avant et c'est vrai que le territoire
tous vraiment de façon à faire en sorte
à ce que le golf national et au golf
dans les yvelines sur une activité
reconnue et elle l'est et je pense que
le format également attiré beaucoup de
personnes parce qu'à la fois être en
capacité d'accueillir cet événement ce
show et ce salon du golf national
golfique sur le site sur lequel il ya eu
la ryder cup les open de france le
concilier à la fois la partie on va dire
exposants et la partie je pense que
c'est très très attractif oui oui est-ce
qu'ils aient du sens finalement
l'organiser ici aux banques nationales
de 50 ans divine ouais ça aurait dû être
fait avant on va dire c'est vrai que
nous on est on est content l'accueillir
parce que c'est vrai que tout le monde
connaît le golf national grâce aux open
grâce à la ryder et le fait de pouvoir
avoir des champions qui sont
actuellement sur le parcours et à
l'avoir tout où on va dire tous les
acteurs économiques sur l'issue du
colloque national - ipsos a vraiment du
sens est ce que ça peut aussi vous
permettre d'attirer de nouveaux clients
peut-être de nouveaux golfeurs ici au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bassam et une
mise en avant bien sûr c'est vrai que
c'est une vraie mise en avant du site et
quoi qu'on en dise même si on est un
site qui est connu et reconnu on a
besoin de ces mises en avant c'est
important et puis à des gens qui
peut-être n'osais pas venir parce que je
disais peut-être qu'au golf national
c'est pas fait pour moi alors qu'on ait
un golf public le goff de la fédération
le golf look est ouvert à tous ça leur
permettait de venir beaucoup plus
facilement oui est-ce que les stands que
vous avez a pu voir qui vous ont qui
vous ont plu à vous aux philippines à
taux bas le nôtre non je plaisante mais
tous les sens sont attractives mais ma
là où je suis le plus heureux c'est de
voir des stands qu'on a là devant nous
avec le portugal qu'elle à la costa
brava qui hélas cirque en fait ce qui
est intéressant ce qui viennent
démarcher la clientèle française parce
que maintenant il ya un vrai marché en
france avec les licenciés qui sont sans
cesse en train de se développer en
volume des licenciés de beaucoup plus
important donc un vrai marché est un
marché français à développer donc oui
c'est là où je suis le plus content le
plus fier est ce qu'il y aura d'autres
éditions à votre avis ici au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
bah oui l'année prochaine à la même date
cc calero calendrier donc l'an prochain
en 2001 2023 on aura en or à cet
événement n'a sur la gueule free qui
aura lieu sur le site du off nationale
oui avec la neige non non non on leur
prochain c'est en polo on enlèvera tout
s'est tenue à et puis en métro mettra
les polos et on va travailler le
bronzage
[Musique]
au total des dizaines de stands ont été
installés sur le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tous en
rapport avec le monde de la petite balle
blanche et certains proposent des
concepts un solide
et on l'a compris aujourd'hui c'est un
petit peu compliqué de jouer au golf en
extérieur et pourquoi pas jouer au golf
en intérieur christian pépin vous avez
conçu un jeu qui est présenté ici dans
ce salon expliquez-nous le concept le
concept ceux de jouer au golf à peu près
au centième de là
à l'échelle 1 centième du jeu de golf
qu'on voit sur le vrai tyran donc il ya
une figurine articulée qui frappe dans
une balle la balle vole sur une certaine
distance
vous pouvez travailler la balle donnée
des effets à la balle on fait des vrais
sortie de bunker et voilà c'est c'est un
jeu de qui représente le golf au
centième c'est quoi un jeu de société
finalement c'est un jeu de société ou un
jeu qu'on peut partager avec des copains
on peut faire des parties un peu comme
on peut faire une partie de billard ou
de subiteo et comment vous est venue
l'idée j'imagine que c'était peut-être
l'hiver comme faisait froid alors l'idée
je sais pas si je peux dire ça comme ça
mais c'était pour créer un jeu de
toucher à l'encontre des jeux vidéo
parce que je considérais que les jeux
vidéo il n'y avait pas de toucher et
donc chez j'ai eu envie de créer un jeu
où il y avait la subtilité dans le
toucher ça fait longtemps que ce jeu
existe alors ce jeu les le premier
module que j'ai fait c'était en 1989 et
le jeu que vous avez derrière lille date
de 2020
voilà j'ai fait j'ai fait deux trois
contre trois prototypes depuis cette
période là et du coup une partie peut
durer combien de temps abba autant que
autant que vaut le volet on peut faire
un parcours entier donc 18 trous c'est
pas une heure et demie 12 heures on le
voit c'est assez imposant combien de
mètres 3 mètre soixante la taille d'un
snooker et il ya aussi des petites
figurines je crois avoir aperçu tiger
woods alors il ya tiger woods bon je
sais pas si on peut et je suis en train
de faire nelly cordes a aussi qui est
très en vogue en ce moment
oui j'ai fait aussi un paint stewart
enfin voila j'ai essayé de faire
différents types de figurines et je fais
aussi des figures et une personnalisé à
la demande et ça coûte combien alors une
figurine sur socle personnalisés ça
coûte 50 euros après un jeu c'est très
difficile a estimé dans la mesure où en
fin de compte je le fais à la demande ce
que des pièces uniques
c'est un jeu qui vaut quand même
relativement cher un jeu comme celui
qu'on voit derrière et vos dix mille
euros et vous en vendez beaucoup est-ce
que ça est ce que ça prend ce jeu alors
bas je suis là pour ça si vous voulez
c'est un jeu que que j'ai créée il ya
très longtemps que j'ai laissées en
suspens pendant 20 ans
là je suis à la retraite depuis 2018 et
depuis 2010 8 j'essaye de de le faire
connaître et c'est pour ça que je suis
venu ici à ce salon
quelques mètres plus loin c'est l'art
qui se met au service du golfe cet
artiste propose de mélanger l'univers
des comics avec les stars de la
discipline des séries limitées qui coûte
entre 400 et 1500 euros
moi je suis à l'origine
directeur artistique de golf magazine le
leader du marché et à mes heures perdues
je fais des petits tableaux créatif avec
mes références de jeunesse savoir les
marvel où je lisais donc ce magnifique
magazine dès mon plus jeune âge
aujourd'hui fan2 fans de golf depuis une
vingtaine d'années et donc j'ai
rassembler ses deux passions pour faire
des créations un peu décalé qui tranche
un peu avec le monde du golf qui
habituellement présentés sous forme de
peintures de lithographie ou une
sculpture maintenant donc voilà
j'assemble ces deux univers un peu
incroyable et ça fait combien de temps
que vous faites ça ça fait ça fait deux
ans que je fais ce que je fais ça
j'avais fait ça il ya deux ans pour pour
le premier salon qu'on devait organiser
qu'on a dû décaler on sait pourquoi avec
la pandémie donc j'ai eu le temps de
faire d'autres oeuvres qui change un
petit peu du monde des super héros
j'avais aussi une représentation pour la
ryder cup qui avait lieu en france avec
la ryder cup donc sur sur ce terrain du
golf national donc voilà je suis sorti
un peu du monde des super héros pour
faire un peu d'autres de création ce
rendez vous était aussi l'occasion
d'approcher au plus près les meilleurs
golfeurs français parmi eux romain
langage
alors romain du coup qu'est ce que
qu'est ce que vous en pensez du coût de
ce salon un coup tu sais c'est quelque
chose de top c'est vrai que la météo est
malheureusement pas pour cette semaine
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important et c'est cool que moi et
d'autres sportifs en tout cas greg
havret bourdier de ça et puis d'être là
parce que je pense que c'est sympa
d'être à leur contact d'être pendant une
période off donc non je trouve que c'est
top c'est plus qu'un salon finalement
cet événement ouais je pense que c'est
un peu le regroupement de la grande
famille du golfe si on prend un sens
large et que nous on puisse être là je
pense que c'est important le lieu du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un lieu où on va dire
unique iconique ouais je pense que c'est
l'icône du golf en france je pense aussi
que année après année ça ira de mieux en
mieux parce que les gens avaient
l'habitude d'être ressemble de paris
pour ce genre d'événement mais je pense
aussi qu'il va y avoir de plus en plus
de deux choses organisé dans le futur
par rapport à ça donc je pense que c'est
voilà ces essais
le groupe national avec le son de
performance avec l'open de france avec
la ryder cup qui a eu c'est le centre du
golf français je pense que c'est bien
que cet événement soit ici
les bâches ils sont compliqués à jouer
ou pas avec cette météo ouais c'est être
ailleurs c'est vrai que c'est pas simple
encore plus pour les amateurs parce que
c'est des trucs sont très compliquée
avec les conditions ça devenait vraiment
injouable donc on a passé un bon moment
entre nous mais après j'espère qu'il
fera meilleur l'année prochaine à
refaire donc à refaire
la nationale golfweek a donc attiré
plusieurs milliers de personnes ici sur
ce golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines rendez vous l'année prochaine
pour une deuxième édition
[Musique]
carabine skis bâtons tout y est ou
presque l'environnement n'est pas tout
blanc mais ce dimanche matin les
adhérents du club de biathlon de
montesson sont à l'entraînement j'aime
bien la glisse mais il va au ski de fond
là des sensations aussi aux tirs je
trouve ça hyper émouvant quand on arrive
à tous bien réussir quand on skie très
bien qu'on arrive à franchir toutes les
cibles la différence et le freinage en
ski de fond tu veux dérapé et là c'est
difficile sinon on tombe et en ski à
roulettes c'est on ne peut plus vite se
faire mal en tombant ce que sur le béton
sarapp mais après les sensations c'est
un peu les mêmes pour stéphane c'est
même le jour de la découverte un
challenge lancé par ses hommes il
savoyard pareil défi de bien regarder si
congé
redresse toi
[Applaudissements]
le début un peu gros mais ça vient c'est
vite salée plus en plus il fait beau
l'ambiance est sympa donc la découverte
intéressante et puis motivant pour
recommencer le club est lancée en
1996 par ceux de tir et athlétique de
montesson et le ski club des yvelines
avec la crise de la covile 17 adhérents
sont toujours présents mais le club a
rassemblé jusqu'à une cinquantaine de
pratiquants la condition physique prime
donc le ski de fond mais également le
tir avec une adresse et puis en mentale
vraiment exceptionnel c'est plutôt
loisirs plutôt loisirs avec découverte
initiation et puis bien entendu les plus
confirmés bien selon leurs demandes
auront la possibilité d'aller faire des
épreuves de longue distance ou du deux
championnats fédéraux certains des
adhérents se rendent régulièrement en
montagne pour évoluer sur la neige la
compétition n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
mais l'entraînement accompagne le
plaisir 122 clubs sont recensés par la
fédération française de ski dans tout
l'hexagone quatre sont présents en ile
de france et roi dans les yvelines
[Musique]
on termine ce 7,8 sport par une triste
nouvelle vincent jacquet ancien dtn de
la fédération française de cyclisme de
2013 à 2017 est décédé mercredi dernier
à l'âge de 52 ans dans son appartement
en suisse il avait notamment marqué les
yvelines lors des championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste en février 2015
organisée au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines il était aux côtés
de l'équipe de france qui avait remporté
sept médailles dont cinq en or
[Musique]